sur cette plage du lac des prés saint
jean il ne reste presque rien du panneau
baignade interdite
il est seulement autorisé de rester au
bord de l'eau même pour pêcher une
obligation que nul n'est censé ignorer
et pour tout ça doit être sûrement
interdite je sais pas mais moi je suis
que j'irais pas me baigner dans un lac
s'est intéressé dans ce lac mais il n'y
a pas de panneaux clairement sait pas
clairement dit en fait c'est légende
l'on dit je n'ai jamais vu de panneaux
stipulant l'interdiction de se baigner
jamais il suffit à ce spécialiste des
milieux aquatiques de marcher quelques
mètres pour constaté plusieurs
infractions
donc là vous avez un carpiste qui est en
action de pêche en bois sont sans eau
diack qui lui permet d'aller déposer ses
lignes hors compétition sur le plan
d'eau des lacs des prés-saint-jean
s'interdit il ne devrait pas y avoir de
bateaux gonflante sur le lac
ce lac artificiel non navigable fait le
bonheur des habitants du quartier depuis
sa création dans les années 60
à la base il servait à l'extraction de
gravier pour alimenter les chantiers une
vocation qui a rendu la profondeur de
l'eau inégale donc là on voit bien sur
le bord du lac que à 4 mètres du bord il
ya un cas un gros caillou et après on
voit le noir du profond là vous avez
plusieurs mètres d'eau sans problème
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun relevé
topographique on voit pas le fond c'est
relativement bouées sur le bord du fait
de la pourriture des de la végétation
glissé il perdre pied le danger concerne
surtout les personnes qui ne savent pas
nager
si les panneaux ont disparu pour
dissuader tout baigneurs des piquets et
des barbelés ont été installés par
endroit la profondeur de l'eau a atteint
jusqu'à 15 mètres